so the other day i was looking through
my youtube videos and i was shocked to
find out i had
no videos on constipation that i could
find
so i decided to do one and this relates
to
two situations one is that you develop
constipation
after you do the ketogenic diet
versus having constipation years before
you do the ketogenic diet
now if you've had constipation your
whole life okay that's a different
situation
i would highly recommend you go to
a doctor that can evaluate that deeper
maybe get some type of scan to look
at your intestines because many times
the large
colon is completely dilated
and distended to the point where it's
going to take a lot of work and a long
time
for people that had long term
constipation and they've tried all sorts
of things i'm going to recommend
some type of herbal laxative i'll put
some links down below
now some people are concerned about
being dependent on herbal laxatives
well the danger of having constipation
or auto intoxication with all those
toxins being recirculated
is much greater than taking an herb
to help you eliminate these toxins
now there's also many other things you
can do for constipation but i'm going to
answer that
when i deal with this other situation
you just started keto and all of a
sudden you got
constipated now i know someone's going
to say in the comment section well what
about diarrhea because that's what i had
i already did a video on that i put the
link down below so you just did keto
you got constipation this is the order
of things that i would take a look at
you want to first adjust your vegetables
a lot of people are not used to seven to
ten cups of vegetables
it may constipate them why because
what is consuming that fiber
is your microbes and you need to kind of
build up these microbes
you may not have enough to deal with
that much
fiber so you may want to start out with
like i don't know
four cups of vegetables slowly go to
five six seven
over time so overloading these microbes
with too much fiber
could constipate you the other point is
too when you
take fiber in it's going to swell up
with fluid
if you're not drinking water after you
consume the vegetables
there could be a problem with kind of
dehydrating your colon
because of the gel effect with fiber it
basically
absorbs water it expands and it helps to
form the stool
so we want to adjust the quantity either
up or down some people
get constipation by consuming a lot of
protein with no vegetables
well then you might want to increase the
vegetables so first thing is increase
the quantity up or down to see if that
handles it
second thing is the type of vegetable if
you're consuming a lot of cruciferous
vegetables some people
don't do well with that they can't
digest it as well
so you might want to switch the type of
vegetables that you consume
it could be like like green lettuce
leaves that might be something you could
do
or asparagus or celery just change the
type
next thing you can do is also switch to
fermented vegetables sauerkraut kimchi
many different types and this is much
easier to digest
the other thing you can do is you can
steam some of your vegetables like maybe
half of them
and have half raw that seems to also
help
the ability to digest and process that
fiber so this would be number one
number two you are not
ready to handle that much fat on the
ketogenic plan
because your bile reserves are not
sufficient so you have a certain amount
of bile that you've been
using to digest food so you switch your
diet to a higher fat diet
and now the requirement for bile goes
up because bile helps you break down fat
it's like the detergent that dissolves
the fat so you may need to add some
purified bile salts after the meal
to assist in the digestion of
the fat okay that's the next thing i
would look at and by the way bile salts
are a natural lubricant so it'll help
you lubricate the colon
and it's actually good for constipation
next thing is you want to add more
potassium potassium
helps the smooth muscle of the colon so
you may want to take some electrolyte
powder you just want to
beef up no pun intended your amount of
potassium
okay number four you add a probiotic of
course you'd want to do
this this and this with the long-term
constipation too but a good probiotic
can help you break down these fibers i
would recommend
something that survives the stomach
acidity
but adding a probiotic is a very vital
thing that you don't want to forget
about
number five add a herbal laxative if you
need it
as a temporary thing and number six b1
if you're deficient in b1 you could lack
the necessary
neurotransmitters to help activate the
muscles in the colon so
b1 naturally helps the peristalsis or
the pumping action
of the colon another common thing that a
lot of people do with keto is to do mct
oil
mct oil has a natural laxative effect
so in the process you may want to use
some of this to help
keep things going all right there you
have it
my video on constipation
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering on keto absolutely not karen
and it's an immune system builder
absolutely
you have to check this out i think you
should hurry up watch the recipe
and make it yourself it's just so easy
to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it